actually it's kind of too bad we're not
coming into work tomorrow why I bet
Michael had some elaborate theme party
planned like scrambled eggs Saturday
I'm like okay everyone let's get your
boss laid Saturday
[Laughter]
I have an announcement uh to make I am
moving to Costa Rica thought about it
for a long time now
and I'm finally going to do it
so
I'm just gonna hop the fence and Jog
home now
so music should we turn some music that
sounds good
do you guys remember my old assistant
Hunter
he is an excellent songwriter wait to
hear this
[Music]
okay
yeah so lost
[Music]
there she is
I swear Phyllis you are as beautiful as
the first day you started work at Dunder
Mifflin
sweet same as when you set it outside
how you doing
you excited yes yes me too if um if you
need to vomit that is okay I did
do you want to talk about tonight no
because I know you're probably worried
about pleasing Bob a lot of pressure
your break with
Rick with very natural reaction it's
your wedding you're nervous
that wasn't me
um
I'm sure that Bob
wow that is
that is pungent
um
I lost my train of thought
ah are you sad on that hairstyle
I thought yeah let me Michael no just I
don't know thank you no Michael please I
just need some time alone okay okay
are you okay
I'm gonna be
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um everyone I'm sorry should I have your
attention please thank you
hi sorry I just have an announcement to
make
um
okay I have learned a lot about Indian
culture tonight
but I have learned even more
about love
and I know you're all thinking who is
this crazy Gringo and what is he talking
about well I'm not crazy
maybe I'm crazy in love
so without further ado
Carol
Carol stills
I would like you to do me the honor
of making me your husband
he's saying
not this in private I didn't hear you
can we talk about this in private
kidding
[Music]
Jayla no no no Jada what are you doing
oh so sorry guys I hope my family didn't
disrupt your meeting Daddy are these the
people who are making your manager
maybe sweetheart
single dad challenges
I don't know if he'd be a good manager
but he's a really great dad okay
was mistake let's go let's go and do you
feel let's take Bob Vance Vance
Refrigeration to be your lawfully wedded
husband
[Music]
the couple Mr and Mrs Bob Vance
and to you Bob take Phyllis to be your
lovely wedded wife
Tony please join your cohorts on the
table if you would
uh this is difficult for me I understand
we're all friends
no I mean I can't physically I can't get
on the table oh well
use the momentum of your lower half to
hoist yourself up
you know what I'll help I will please
don't don't be shy Dwight let's do this
come on we're doing this thing let's get
up on three one two the knees okay here
we go here we go I'm under this I'm
under this Hawk here
I don't know what I'm grabbing here
I'm right in your crap
you got it you got it right now
what are you doing what are you doing
I'm objecting here yes I didn't
and I have a ride home
we sit in the back
there's this guy he's at a nymphomaniac
convention and he is psyched because all
these women are smoking hot perfect tens
except for this one chick who looks a
lot like uh fellas yeah no no no no that
crosses the line excuse me
not you
Kevin
just unwarranted
hostile work environment Kevin Packer
said it no you said it he pointed a
point is not a say look Kevin
we are a family here
and Phyllis is a valued member of that
family like a grandmother I'm the same
age as you Michael well I don't know
about that we're the same high school
well I have a late birthday and usually
September is a cut off point
you know what you just crossed the line
okay there's a line and you went over it
and you must be punished so go to your
corner
you mean where my desk is yes your
corner vote okay
I have a lot of work to do anyway
oh my they really got to you didn't they
they didn't get to me
I got to them
I am still the same old Michael Scott
new and improved
you know what
I love Phyllis
you know what else
I think she is gorgeous
I think she is an incredibly incredibly
attractive person
come here come here come on come on you
don't have to worry I'm not reported I'm
not worried to HR you know what the only
thing I am worried about I'm getting a
boner
good work today everybody